STAN LEE
I love being with people
It's the most incredible thing in the world.
PETER PARKER
What are you doing?
Oh, this is nice.
STAN LEE
That world may change and evolve.
But the one thing that will never change,
we're all part of one big family.
GROOT
We
are
Groot.
STAN LEE
That man next to you,
he's your brother.
That woman over there,
she's your sister.
CAROL DANVERS
Higher, further, faster, baby!
MARIA RAMBEAU
That's right!
STAN LEE
We're all part of one Universe.
BLACK PANTHER
Wakanda forever!
STAN LEE
That moves ever upward
and onward to greater glory!
FALCON
On your left.
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
CAPTAIN AMERICA
AVENGERS!
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
CAPTAIN AMERICA
Assemble!
[AUDIENCE CHEERING]
BLACK WIDOW
I've lived a lot of lives,
but I’m done running from my past.
We have unfinished business.
YELENA BELOVA
Who's we?
When you love something
you fight for it.
We're the ones who changed everything.